[Music]
there's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry
world upon world entire civilizations
far more than we ever theorized it's
okay
passing through we stake now claim
[Music]
[Music]
there
[Music]
so how long have you been Antonin again
no uh I just sort of happened it's like
bad guys like you
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be goals
tonight walks to walls and stuff slowly
uptick now supposed to take over the
world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house
happy because we probably do you
remember that's us feeling everybody is
both a man and the wasp teaming up
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny I
was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you've 65 feet 65 if you
do our flesh comparing sizes 65
[Music]